yeah it looks good uh great
okay okay thank you so much for having
me um
it's great to speak to you all and today
i'll talk about
the latest installment in a line of
works
that aim to develop a new kind of um
classical simulation of quantum circuits
based on stabilized decompositions
and so this work that i'll talk about at
the end of this talk
is joined with hamam qasim and hakap
bashayan
and uh it uh it builds on some
works that i you know have their origins
in the goddess mcniel theorem
but also um were pioneered by hector
garcia ramirez and his phd thesis from
2014
as well as robbie smith and smallwood
smelling 2015 and many later works
so i'll also talk about the sort of
general framework and motivation
talk please do feel free to interrupt
with questions
you have to answer them during the talk
okay
so the topic is classical simulation of
quantum circuits
and the basic setting is that we have a
circuit that we want to simulate on a
classical computer and the circuit you
know it starts with
the all zeros state and then at the end
we want to measure some subset of the
qubits in the computational basis
and so the measurement probability
distribution is over
w bit strings where w is at most n the
number of qubits in the circuit
and there are you know different
classical simulation tasks that you
might wish to consider
one is strong simulation and
this is the problem where you're given a
binary string
and asked to compute its probability in
the output distribution
this is not something that quantum
computers can do efficiently
but you could of course hope to do it
with a classical computer
um this task is sharply hard and um
this is sort of the hardest of the
classical simulation tasks that we'll
discuss in this talk
there's also a notion of weak simulation
where you sample a bit string from the
distribution
p the output distribution and here we're
going to
i guess it's not written here but here i
mean to within some inverse polynomial
total variation distance and this is
something that quantum computers can do
even in the presence of noise say using
quantum air correction
um and there is a sort of in-between
task which is to
uh i'll call it epsilon strong
simulation where you're given a binary
string and you're asked to compute an
approximation of the output probability
corresponding to that binary string
to within epsilon relative error your
epsilon can be
a constant or perhaps inverse polynomial
and this is sort of almost as hard as uh
strong simulation i mean it's
it's sharply hard and again quantum
computers can't do this
now like what are the
algorithms for classically simulating
quantum circuits well
you know we believe that quantum
computers are more powerful and so um
you know most algorithms have
exponential scaling either in the number
of qubits or even worse in the number of
gates
so the most naive algorithm you you
might store the
state of the quantum computer in
classical memory as a complex vector
with to the n
entries and then just multiply you know
each gate as a sparse matrix update to
this vector
this is an algorithm which requires
exponential memory just to store the
state
and also has a runtime that is
exponential in them
um if you want to compute say an
amplitude of the given circuit
you can also do it using like a feynman
path type
sum over paths approach and this will
reduce the memory requirements to
polynomial
but the runtime now is exponential in
the number of gates which is
without loss of generality at least the
number of cubits
um this algorithm was recently improved
actually to scale like the depth to the
number of qubits so this
removes the exponential scaling with the
number of gates and replaces it with an
exponential and analog d
while maintaining the memory
requirements being polynomial and now
uh this is due to heronson and chen
and you know these algorithms as i said
have exponential scaling in the number
of qubits or the number of gates
uh but there are there are settings in
which it's possible to
simulate chrome circuits in in
with less classical runtime and most of
those settings
are that i'm aware of involve tensor
network contraction methods
which have their origins and work of
markov and she from 2005.
and the idea of those methods is to view
the circuit as a tensor network so
uh you know every every wire in the
quantum circuit represents an index and
you have to contract all of the indices
to compute say
an amplitude of the circuit like the one
represented here
and you want to choose the ordering of
those contractions to minimize the
memory and runtime of the classical
simulation
so for example if you have this
sort of one-dimensional circuit and you
want to compute the amplitude that's
depicted here
you could first contract all the indices
in the yellow box
to form a sort of yellow tensor and you
could also contract separately all the
indices in the orange box
so that would result in a tensor network
where now you have these
you know tensors the yellow and orange
tensors connected to these three other
gates
and then you could contract you know all
of the indices that are contained within
this red box
and then in the final step you have some
this tensor represented in red and you
just need to compute some entry of that
tense
and this kind of like sequential um
uh you know contraction of tensors
uh can be beneficial when the circuit
has a nice geometry
and in some cases for example like in 2d
circuits and two-dimensional circuits or
one-dimensional circuits
the scaling can be much less than
exponential in the number of qubits
so it's good because the runtime of
these algorithms depends on the
connectivity of the circuit and can be
better than exponential moon
but one drawback of these methods or one
limitation is that they're
typically insensitive to the entries of
the gates that appear
so they you know no matter what gates
they are you just contract them
using the same kind of formula
and this limitation was uh sort of
formalized by hwang newman and segetti
who defined a family of monotone
simulation methods
that captures most tensor network
contraction methods
and they showed that in the worst case
so if you don't have a nice geometry to
exploit for example
these methods will have runtime that is
exponential enamel
and so this talk is about a different
kind of simulation algorithm that um
builds on the goddess mcniel theorem and
you know
which fundamentally uses the gates that
appear in the circuit
and you know is separate from this
family this
class of monotone simulation methods
okay so that brings me to the part of
the talk where i'm going to tell you
about these stabilizer rank simulators
specifically for clifford plus t
circuits so i think many of us
or all of us know about the clifford
group which is generated by
a single qubit hadamard phase and two
qubit c not gates
and we all know the goddess mcniel
theorem that such circuits can be
efficiently simulated on a classical
computer
in any sense really that you want to
imagine like weekly or strongly
simulated in particular
and the sort of starting point for these
methods that i'll discuss today is the
question of whether or not we can
extend the gauss mcnail simulation
method to circuits with a few
non-clifford gates
so you might for example take the
clifford plus t gate set where we would
join the single qubit t gate
and ask what is the classical simulation
cost of a circuit with m
t gates so if m is zero it should be
polynomial in the number of qubits
the number of gates and if m is one or
two or three
you know we should have some kind of
scaling or understanding of the scaling
of the simulation with m
so the strategy that has been used to do
these sorts of simulations
is based on or one of the strategies i
should say
is based on uh taking your clifford plus
t circuit
and gadgetizing it in the following way
so this
this uh diagram which appeared in this
paper from 2000 by chang which is well
known
um it shows how you can implement a
t-gate
using the so-called single qubit magic
state written here so this is a
non-stabilizer state
along with clifford operations and
classical control
so if you take a clifford plus t circuit
and you replace
all instances of the t gate with this
gadget
then you'll get a so-called gadgetized
circuit
which is an adaptive clifford circuit
and
um the input state is the original input
state so all zeros
along with m copies of the single qubit
magic state
okay um so that kind of pushes all of
the non-cliffordness into the input
state
and then the simulation algorithms you
know
follow a fairly straightforward approach
so you have this input state you have
this adaptive clifford operation and
then you have the final measurement
and the simulation strategy is first to
approximate the input magic state so
this is a non-stabilizer state
it falls outside of the stabilizer
formalism so the first step is to
approximate it as a superposition
of you know hopefully much less than two
to the n stabilizer states because we
want to have an algorithm that
has a scaling that's better than
exponential and or sorry
that's uh better than two to the n in
terms of its runtime
so the first step is to approximate this
input magic state in that way
and then for each term in this
superposition
we can apply the clifford operation
to each term individually and each time
we apply a clifford operation to a
stabilizer state
we can do that in polynomial time so the
run time of these first two steps
assuming we have at our disposal a good
approximation to the input magic state
the runtime of these steps is
essentially up to polynomial
factors it's linear in this chi
quantity in the last step you want to
simulate this final measurement
or you know if you're doing strong
simulation you might want to
actually just compute the output
probability and the cost of this step
actually depends on the type of
simulation that you're going for
so a kind of naive thing that you can do
for example if you're interested in
strong simulation where you want to
actually compute the output probability
um well then you need to compute this
quantity here
which is uh you know the output
probability is a marginal probability of
the full output distribution on n qubits
and you can see that from this
expression that it's quadratic in the
output state
psi so if the output state psi is the
superposition of chi
stabilizer states then this expression
that i've written here on the slide
is a superposition of chi squared
amplitudes or sorry inner products
between stabilizer states
and so for strong simulation
in fact the best run time we have of
this last step is chi squared
and for uh for
weak simulation or epsilon strong
simulation
there is a better strategy that one can
use
which uses a a sub routine that we call
the norm estimation algorithm in our
paper from 2016
which brings down the runtime of this
step to also linear and chi
so it's an open question whether or not
um
strong simulation can also be made
linear in the stabilized rank
but if we're interested in either weak
or epsilon strong simulation then
everything is
linear in this kai kwang but i have not
been
sort of completely
you know precise about what chi is i
said that we need to approximate this
input magic state
but i didn't say what kind of
approximation is needed for these
simulation tasks
and of course the other question is how
big does chi need to be
so first let's talk about what kind of
approximation is needed
and this brings us to the notion of
stabilizer bank
so bravi smith and smolin defined
the stabilizer rank of a state psi to be
the minimum
integer r such that psi can be written
as a superposition of r stabilizer
states with equality
so this is you know in this talk we'll
call it the stabilizer rank or
we might call it the exact stabilizer
rank to distinguish it from
the quantity which we call the
approximate stabilizer rank which has a
error tolerance delta the approximate
stabilizer rank is the minimum r
such that psi is approximated to within
error delta by a superposition of our
stabilized states
and typically we're interested in delta
being a small constant or
inverse polynomial in the number of
cubes
uh let me before talking getting back to
simulation
i want to just make a remark about
stabilizer decompositions
um you know a stabilizer state you may
know this or you may not
it's well known that a stabilizer state
can be parametrized
in terms of in the following ways so any
stabilizer state is proportional to
a superposition over all binary or
computational basis states
in an affine subspace of f2 to the n and
the phase of each computational basis
state is determined
by a quadratic boolean function q of x
and a linear boolean function l of x in
the following way
so i just want to uh remark that if we
take real equatorial state legislates by
which i mean
we take the linear function to be zero
and the offline subspace to be all
binary strings
then these these stabilizer states just
correspond exactly to the set of
quadratic boolean functions
and so when we think about stabilizer
decompositions and we think about
decomposing a given state into the over
complete basis of stabilizer states
you can think of that as a more general
task that generalizes
the decomposition of a boolean function
into quadratic boolean functions
which is the subject of a quadratic
fourier analysis of boolean functions
that has been studied in
computer science okay so that's just a
remote
um but getting back to simulation
so the classical simulation cost as i
mentioned scales
with the stabilizer rank of the magic
state input and so if you have
n qubits g total gates and mt gates
here are the the scalings of these
quantities so as i mentioned the strong
simulation is quadratic
in chi and here the relevant quantity is
the exact stabilizer rank
because we actually want an exact
estimate of the output probabilities
for epsilon strong or weak simulation
the
runtime is linear and for epsilon strong
simulation you need to use the exact
stabilizer rank as far as we know
whereas for weak simulation it suffices
to use the approximate stabilizer rank
so a couple of remarks these techniques
can be extended to circuits with other
non-clifford gates
this was done in a paper
from 2018 and in this very very tiny box
there is a plot which you can barely see
and um
you know i just wanted to include a plot
that sort of
and mentioned just as a reminder to
mention to you that these techniques
have been used like this plot
is a simulation of a 50 qubit qaoa
circuit
as a function of some angle that appears
in the in the
in the circuit and this this this
circuit uses 66 non-clifford gates
and you know those gates um vary
in terms of what they are they're always
a z-rotation so somewhere in the middle
of the plot is 66 t-gates and then
there's um other z-rotations as the
x-axis changes so
this is the only plot i'm going to show
in this in this talk but i just wanted
to mention
that these techniques have been
implemented and used and and
they can be used for for certain
circuits like these qaoi circuits with a
few non-clifford gates
um another remark is as i mentioned
before the classical simulation has
linear scaling the stabilizer rank
and so you know that
we just need to understand the
stabilizer rank to understand the limits
of these
of these methods um unfortunately
it's somewhat difficult to understand
these quantities
um you know it's very easy to see that
the exact stabilizer rank
of m copies of the magic state must
increase
exponentially with m or else sharp p
complete problems can be solved in
polynomial time
with classical advice that tells you the
decomposition of m copies of the
of the magic state into stabilizer
states and since this is very unlikely
to occur we know that this quantity
should
should certainly increase exponentially
with m
similar statements can be made about the
approximate stabilized rank
but the best unconditional lower bound
on this quantity is actually just linear
now which was already an improvement
over a
square root m bound that appeared in
probably smith and smaller
so there's a long way to go in terms of
lower bounds on the stabilizer
and in the rest of this talk i want to
tell you about the upper bounds and how
they're obtained
and i'm going to kind of just take it
for granted that you care about this
problem and that you find it interesting
to just understand the
best classical simulation cost as a
function of the number of
non-clifford gates or t-gates in this
case um
are there any questions at this point
a question
so if you have a state that decomposes
into m
stabilizer states so it still is
maybe not a chi
you need to compute the amplitudes
acceptance amplitudes of the each piece
right not just
the not just the acceptance
probabilities because
would it there be
like you know the because you have a
superposition over the stabilizer states
so
there might be cancellations in their
areas
yeah um so wouldn't you need a stronger
simulation like
not just computing the output
probability but also the
output amplitude um
well okay so um
let's just consider the very simplest
situation where you want to compute
um like an n bit or n qubit output
amplitude so the output register is all
n cubed
so then you know like let's say you want
to compute the inner product with all
zeros
so then you can just take your
stabilizer decomposition
and sum up the inner product of all the
stabilizer states with all zeros
with their corresponding coefficients so
that is clearly linear in chi
and the reason that strong simulation
has this chi squared
comes from the fact that we consider a
task where you can compute marginals as
well
and that that causes this quadratic
scaling with chi
rather than linear i'm not sure if that
answers your question
i guess my question was but what are the
guarantees of the strong simulation
so the the is that you can compute a
marginal probability so in other words
the output probability of some
uh you know some binary string
occurring on the first k cube let's say
that's the task considered here if you
wanted to compute amplitudes
um you can certainly do that and the
cost is only linear in chi
but there we're talking about n qubit
amplitudes as opposed to like some kind
of marginal
amplitude which i'm not sure how you
would define it
does that make sense
sort of think about it okay
i guess my point is just that computing
an n qubit amplitude is actually
like it's easier than the strong
simulation task
because you don't have to compute a
marginal
so to compute an n cubit amplitude would
require time linear in chi
okay um thanks
so upper bounds and
i want to give a kind of overview of
what is known and
the kind of improvement that we give in
our latest work
and end with some kind of open questions
because i think there's
quite a few so in this work with sergey
from 2016 we gave the following upper
bound on the approximate stabilizer rank
of m
magic states and so i mean it's written
here as 2 to the alpha m
in terms of the exponential scaling just
because i want to compare it with the
scaling that we get later on for the
exact stabilizer rank
and here alpha is this quantity
which is roughly 0.228 so it's kind of a
mild scaling
um but you know true to the alpha m is
like one over it's exactly equal to one
over cosine pi over h
squared to the m so this is you know
uh arguably more naturally written as
that but i'm writing it this way because
i want to compare it with with later
later quantities how do you obtain this
upper bounds
well it's very easy actually so first
we can identify another single cubit
state let's call it h
which is a superposition of the single
qubit zero state
and the single qubit plus state the
uniform superposition
because those two states are not
orthogonal the
normalizing constant is not one over
root two it's this funny thing one over
two cosine pi over a
so this single qubit state is clifford
equivalent to a in other words it can be
written as a clifford applied to a
so instead of looking at the stabilizer
rank of a tensor m we may as well look
at the stabilizer rank of h tensor m
now just from this formula that i wrote
down
we can see that each tensor m is exactly
equal to
a uniform superposition of
states in a non-orthogonal basis where
each basis state is labeled by
an n-bit string an embed string and here
like the zero state is the zero state
and the one state is the plus state
okay so this is just an exact expression
using this funny identity above
and you know to go for so this this
expression here is exact but it has
stabilizer rank 2 to the
m as written i mean each of those x hat
states
is a stabilizer state it's in fact a
product stabilizer state
so this has a stabilizer rank 2 to the m
but the main observation is that you can
get rid of many of the terms in this sum
and still have a good approximation to
this state
so what we show is that if you restrict
the sum to a linear subspace
which is randomly chosen and has size
roughly given by
what is written above like delta to the
minus 2 to the alpha m
we you choose a random subspace in that
way and you
only include the terms x that are in
that subspace
in the above sum you will get a delta
approximation to h tends around
and so um we can just you know
this is the proof sketch and if you want
the details of how this is done
you can look at our paper but it's it's
not much more complicated than that
so um i should mention that the scaling
with delta
was improved in later work to one over
delta but
um for maybe the purposes of this talk
we're more interested in the scaling
with
m and you know you might ask whether or
not the scaling with m in this case is
optimal
and i would argue that um there are
some good reasons to think that it might
be well first of all
one over cosine squared pi over eight to
the m is a sort of
nice um it's a nice number at least and
it's
you know cosine pi over 8 seems to be
related to the t8 so that's
you know it passes the smell test but
perhaps more importantly you can show
that the scaling is optimal
under certain restrictions on the
stabilizer states appearing in the
decomposition
so for example if you assume that the
gram matrix formed by the stabilizer
states that appear
has a non-negligible
spectral gap then then the scaling is
optimal
you can also show that among
decompositions into this
x-hat basis it's optimal
and moreover
if you look at the stabilizer
decomposition itself
and instead of looking at the rank as
the measure of optimality if instead you
look at the one norm
of the coefficients then this
stabilization composition is
optimal in terms of that one norm which
is a quantity that we study in this
in this 2018 paper so there are kind of
a few data points that
might convince you that this is a
natural uh exponential scaling with them
and maybe it turns out to be optimal but
of course
we have no matching lower bound and the
best lower bound we have is
um very far away from this so
so all bets are off um
but in contrast like if we look at the
exact stabilized rank so now the
you know decompositions with no error
then
the best the best known upper bounds on
that quantity
seem very you know they they're almost
certainly not optimal i mean there's no
it would be astounding to me if the
current best bounds were optimal
um so let me tell you about how the
previously known upper bounds
uh work so the the first thing
um that is done is to upper bound the
stabilizer rank of just some constant
number of magic states
so for example like you might take you
know three or four or five or six
magic states and some one way or another
you
try to find an upper bound on the
stabilizer rank of a tensor
c where c is that constant
then you know the stabilizer ink has a
kind of trivial
sub multiplicativity because if we take
a stabilized decomposition of phi
and a stabilized decomposition of psi
and we just tensor them together
then we get a stabilizer decomposition
of phi tensor psi
because the tensor product of stabilizer
states is always itself a stabilized
state
so this gives us this kind of trivial
sub-multiplicativity
and basically what it says is that if we
want to uh get a stable azure
decomposition of m
copies of the magic state we can just
block the m
states into blocks of size c and then
use our decomposition for
uh for c magic states and then take it
you know the rank will be
whatever the rank is for c magic states
to the power of m over c
so this is kind of the strategy that has
been used
and um you know you might not be
surprised that
this or or it might be like
clear that this is probably not going to
give the right answer in terms of the
proper scaling with m just by looking at
some small number of magic statements
and blocking uh blocking to get larger
numbers
but this first step even though it
sounds very easy like to just look at a
constant number of magic states never
been on the stabilizer rank
this step is really not very easy at all
and so let me just show you a table from
robbie smith and smolin from 2015.
so here um the table shows n from two to
six
and the upper bounds that are computed
in that paper
which which go from two to seven and
they
they say that they believe these upper
bounds are tight
and the way they compute these upper
bounds is using a heuristic algorithm
which is a kind of simulated annealing
search
and you know let's just look for a
moment at this
case of n equals six and chi equals
seven
so when like what is the size of the
search space for the heuristic search in
that case
well when n is six the number of six
qubit stabilizer states is about 315
million
and in this search they're searching
over subsets
of seven six qubit stabilizer states
so the number of subsets of seven six
qubit stabilizer states
is this number choose 7 which is more
than 10 to the 48.
so even though you know it sounds like
kind of straightforward to like just
take a constant number of
magic states and decompose them into
stabilized states
this is like a real challenge even for n
equals six and k equals seven
and um i will show you later that this
statement that
you know the belief that these upper
bounds are tight turns out not to be
correct
okay um so the best bound from that
paper was the last one in the last
column that we just looked at
and it says that six magic states have
stabilizer rank at most seven
and um you know just by this blocking
argument this implies that
12 magic states has stabilized rank at
most 49
and that was um improved by lucas cosia
in a paper
in 2020 who showed that 12 magic states
have stabilized rank at most 47
and the technique that he used to do
that is opaque to me
but this is what he obtained by
explicitly showing a stabilized
decomposition of a tensor 12.
now if you now implement the second step
of using sub-multiplicativity
what you get from robby smith and smolin
is that the
exponential scaling of a tensor m
of the stabilizer rank is 2 to the alpha
m where alpha
is roughly 0.4679
and using the improvement from lucas's
paper from 2020
you would get 0.4629 so the improvement
of the third digit
and that was the best known upper bound
and so like in this
recent work we improve on this bound
using
a different strategy and um i
i can't say that we uh you know
understand what we think is the best
possible scaling but we give a
significant over
improvement over these previous balance
uh so what is the strategy so the
strategy is based on
uh instead of looking at magic states we
look at these magic cap states
here's a picture of a cat in a hat and
apparently you can buy that hat on the
internet
um so this is a magic cat state with m
qubits it's a superposition
of a m and a purp tensor m
a is the single cubit state orthogonal
to a
which is obtained by just applying the z
pal the operator to a
so if we take this magic cat state like
a sort of simple observation is that its
stabilizer rank
is upper bounded by that of m magic
states and it's lower bounded by half
the stabilizer rank about magic states
so it's always within a factor of two
and both of these bounds are very easy
to see
the first one you know the upper bound
it just follows because you can write
the cat state as
a stabilizer projector acting on m
copies of the magic state
and the stabilizer projector which is
shown in yellow here
does not increase stabilizer rank so if
you take a stability decomposition of a
tensor m
and now act with the stabilizer
projector on each term in the
decomposition
you get a stabilizer decomposition of
cat m with the same rank
and a similar argument can be used to
obtain this lower bound
uh one can express magic states as a
single cube projector onto a
on the first qubit acting on the
cap state and that single qubit operator
in yellow
can be written as a sum of two cliffords
each of which doesn't increase
stabilizer rank
so if you plug in a stabilizer
decomposition of the cap state
and then decompose this projector in
yellow as a sum of two cliffords
you get the stabilizer decomposition of
m copies of the magic state with almost
twice the rank
it's the lower bound so this is a very
simple observation
and what it says is that the stabilizer
rank of this magic cat state has the
same asymptotic scaling with m
i mean it's always within a factor of
two um
but of course you know because of this
factor of two like stabilizer
decompositions of these magic cats with
small
m are much easier to find so for example
if you take the one qubit magic cat
state
then it's just the stabilizer state just
the zero state
so it's a stabilizer state likewise the
two cubit magic cap state
is also a stabilizer state
and we can compute the stabilized rank
of magic cap states all the way up to m
equals six
exactly and the stabilized rank of six
the six cubic magic cat state is equal
to three
the way that we show that is just by
exhibiting
uh decomposition into three stabilizer
states which we found by hand
and the lower bound and i'll come back
to this later but the lower bound
is um shown by establishing that no
state with stabilizer rank at most two
can have the same set of poly
expectation values and this
is i in my opinion even though it's not
too bad
it's more work than it should be to show
a lower bound on stabilizer rank of
three
and um you know improvements to the sort
of techniques for even just showing this
sort of thing would be very
uh interesting i think okay well anyways
so we know that um
the the stabilizer rank of the six cubic
magic cat state is
is three and this already gives some
very low hanging fruit
if we want to improve the runtime of
these algorithms for classical
simulation
because you know just using the fact
that
m magic states has stabilized rank at
most twice that of the cat state
we get an upper bound on six copies of
the magic state
where the rank is at most six which
falsifies the conjecture from robbie
simpson smalling that is equal to seven
which was the bound that they found
using their heuristic search
um and you know then using this uh tried
and true method of multiplicativity or
blocking
we get a classical simulation algorithm
or an upper bound on chi
which is um you know improved to 0.4308
from roughly 0.46 something
so this this already is the best upper
bound
but it turns out that we can do better
than this even just using the
ingredients that i've already mentioned
by using them in a slightly different
way
so the the thing that we're going to do
is we're going to build the big
magic cap states out of small ones
rather than converting our small magic
cat state into m copies of the magic
state
and let me give you an example like
suppose we have
two magic cats each of size m
written here um one thing we could do is
we could
uh contract with two copies of the magic
state on qubits
m and m plus one and so we would be
um projecting each of these states onto
the
a tensor m minus one state so we would
get two m minus two copies of the magic
state
the second line i've contracted with a
perp a per
and there you've got two m minus two
copies of p per
now if we sum these two equations we see
that
contracting two copies of the cat state
on m qubits
with just a cap two state which is a
stabilizer state
we can get uh two m minus two cubic cat
state
so if we do an accounting of the
stabilizer ranks here i mean
the stabilizer rank of cat two is one
the stabilizer rank of each of these cat
states is
chi of cat m and so what we get is that
the stabilizer rank
of a 2m qubit roughly about two and
minus two cubic cat state
is at most the stabilizer rank of the m2
cat state square
so for example if we take our two copies
of cat six and contract with one copy of
cat two
which is depicted here in this picture
then we get that the stabilizer rank of
cap 10 is at most three squared which is
nine
and you know plugging this now
converting this into a bound on
the stabilizer anchor magic states we
get an even
better exponent than we had before just
by
directly using our stabilizer rank of
cat6 now
but it turns out that an even better
strategy is to contract many copies of
cat6
arranged in a chain in a very long chain
and so here
if we have l copies of cat6 and l minus
one copies of cat two all of which are
stabilizer
what we end up with is roughly four l
cop
four roughly four l cubic cascade
because each of the cat6 states
two of the qubits get removed except for
on the ends
by the contraction so we end up with
four l uh
cubic cat stay roughly and the
stabilizer rank bound that we get from
this contraction
is the six cubic cat state stability to
the power of l
which is three to the l and taking l to
be large and setting m
to be the total number of qubits we get
an upper bound on the stabilizer rank of
the m cubic cap state
which is 2 to the alpha m where alpha is
0.3962
so this is also an upper bound on the
stabilizer rank of magic states
asymptotically since
those two things are always within a
factor of two of each other
so that's the best bound that we
establish in our paper on the stabilized
rank of magic states
and it upper bounds as i mentioned the
runtime of epsilon strong simulation of
quadrature plus t
circuits as a function of the number of
t gates
but there's still a big gap between this
scaling and that of the approximate
stabilizer rank which is the weak
simulation cost
where the best upper bound has alpha to
be roughly 0.28
in our paper we do some more things uh
one is that we
upper bound the stabilizer rank of
symmetric states um
and we get so for example if you have
any single qubit state scientific
and copies of it you give an upper bound
of two to the m
or two on its stabilizer rank and this
can be used to
compute output probabilities of circuits
with
non-cleaver gates that are not the t
gate for example
perhaps uh more a more
interesting thing is that we generalize
this
magic cat state strategy to
um to use rather i mean if you view the
magic cat state as a superposition over
the
basis vectors of the reputation code in
the magic basis
then you could also just consider
instead of using the magic cat state
you could consider a family of states
that are parametrized by linear codes
and correspond to superpositions of both
states in the magic basis
and we show how you can get an upper
bound on the stabilized rank of magic
states
by contracting this kind of state and
you know the upper bound depends on the
stabilizer rank of chi of l so if you
can
upgrade on the stabilizer ring of kybell
the code has to have dimension
that goes to him over two then you will
get enough you know you can plug it into
this formula that we derive in our paper
and you will get an upper bound on the
stabilizer rank of magic states
and you know the bound that we get it
agrees with our
best bound obtained using cat states and
maybe there are codes where you know you
can upper bound chi of l and get a
better bound we don't know
um there are many open questions i mean
obviously we've not solved all the
problems here
one is that we have no non-trivial
criterions for certifying that a given
state has stabilized rank
at least k even for k equals three or
four or five like
it's uh we have no way of understanding
what the stabilized rank of a
of a given state is so that that would
be a useful thing to know
um obviously we'd like to establish
super polynomial lower bounds on
stabilized rank because they have to
scale exponentially with them
and improve the upper bounds that are
given in this paper
and finally you know you could imagine
applying these methods to classical
counting problems
um maybe i'll i'll leave it there and
here's a table of our best bounds on
stabilizer rank of m
copies of the magic state and the m
qubit cad state
for small values of it thank you
thanks david um there's a question in
the chat from honorable
yes uh does um kai delta the smooth
version
involves minimizing the stabilizer rank
over all easy to describe states close
to
a tensor n there could be very
complicated states with low stabilizer
rank but they would be useless for
stimulation
i think i think the question is about
you know if the
if the state is extremely complicated
you know then can you use it in
classical simulation
and i guess i guess it's kind of like a
non-uniform thing right like we're
imagining that you have this
i mean certainly it's true that the um
the decompositions we know of are simple
and so they don't add to the simulation
cost just to compute the decomposition
but it could be that for each m the
optimal decomposition
you know has a very complicated
dependence on m and maybe is itself hard
to compute as a function of m
and so there we would be talking now
about classical simulation cost with
this kind of classical advice which
tells you the decomposition
can you say um so just as a
big picture i had in my mind slightly
different for the whole
circuit was just thinking of the t-gate
as decomposed into paulie's
combination of police and then sort of
uh working with that instead of sort of
going
uh is there so so can we translate what
you're doing
into that picture somehow yeah you can
uh it turns out that for the tk the best
strategy to use is not to decompose into
pallies but into cliffords
so you should decompose for the t-gate
if you want the optimal algorithm along
those lines i mean we discussed this in
our 2018 paper
the optimal way to do that is to
decompose the t8 as
a superposition of the identity gate and
the phase gate
so it's not a pally but a clifford but
yes you can
you can do things that way as well but
then so then these
so sorry sorry does anything that you've
done here sort of
say something there yeah the translation
between the sort of sum over clifford's
method
and the gadgetized method uh there are
as far as i know only partial results um
so i don't think we have a it's not
because what you're talking about is
decomposing a unitary
and here we're talking about decomposing
states and in some situations
you can map one to the other but i think
we don't know
a general way to obtain a decomposition
of
the unitary from a decomposition of the
state
there's a question in the q a um
and i'll read it so the question is what
sort of structure
is there in the stabilizer
decompositions
do you think the lower qubit
decompositions
be generalized somehow
yeah i think maybe i can just answer a
slightly more general question or
interpret it
in a more general setting i mean
basically i think that understanding
the structure of like sets of stabilizer
states
like for example understanding what kind
of gram matrices you can get
from sets of stabilizer states and the
subspaces that they span
if you know it just we don't have a good
handle on that and that's the reason why
we're playing around with
these techniques that use you know
stabilizing compositions into six
stabilizer states or something like that
there's we have very little
understanding of that and i think the
same is true in
this sort of quadratic fourier analysis
field i mean
you know if you look at what is known
there
as far as i can tell there are not big
results that help us resolve these
questions about
you know the number of the number of
quadratic functions needed to
expand a given boolean function for
example
okay thanks a lot david and thanks to
all the speakers in this session
[Applause]
back at uh